more than 3,000 students returned to
class this morning at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School the Florida School
has significant security upgrades for
the new school year since a gunman
killed 17 people in February shooting
changes include more surveillance
cameras a single point of entry and more
security staff Adriana Diaz is outside
the school in parkland with why some
students say the changes don't go far
enough
Adriana a good morning good morning
there are counselors and therapy dogs
here for students and the building where
the shooting occurred has been blocked
off by a 12-foot fence to make up for
that classroom space the school brought
in trailers designed as portable
classrooms but despite those changes and
the extra security students we spoke to
said they still don't feel safe in the
run-up to the new school year school
spirit was already on full display but
superintendent Robert Runcie
acknowledged it won't be easy it will be
emotional it will be difficult as we
remember the victims their families
faculty and staff and everyone in this
entire community Runcie says that the
school students are returning to will be
far more secure the number of on campus
security personnel has doubled from 9 to
18 that includes three armed school
resource officers more security cameras
have been installed along with a single
entry point system students and staff
will be required to wear IDs at all
times and upgrades have been made to
classroom doors so they lock
automatically it doesn't make me feel
safer no not at all
I'm not gonna feel safe in school I
don't feel safe anywhere at this point
in my life
senior class president Jacqueline Korn
is a leader among student activists we
won't stop until this as you gets fixed
she and others spent most of the summer
traveling across the country promoting
gun reform and voter turnout until we
actually remove of these weapons of war
from our streets and we're not gonna
feel safe you know we gonna have all the
security we want we can have bulletproof
backpacks for all I care
fifteen year-old Anthony bore heads was
shot five times during February's
rampage
he says he's too afraid to go back to
school why are you not going back to
school
I don't feel say because maybe another
Nicholas screw it there
maybe there's another Nicholas Cruz the
people want their kids to be safe and
they want their teachers safe also in
the schools
Andrew Pollock lost his daughter meadow
in the attack he believes the school
board has failed students they're really
just putting a bandaid on the situation
the father of Anthony bore has who was
shot five times says he won't send his
son back to school until there is new
leadership at the school board as most
students go back to school
the shooter Nicholas Cruz goes back to
court he has a hearing today that could
set his trial date gale
Adriana thank you I could see why it
would be very unsettling for those kids
to go back you got to get back in the
swing it's and their parents right
exactly wishing them a very good day
today